السيد الرئيس ، من السابق
لأوانه القول ما إذا كان هذا الصاروخ
قد تم إطلاقه من روسيا ،
هناك معلومات أولية
يمكن أن تختبر أنني لا أريد أن أقول ذلك
حتى نقوم بالتحقيق الكامل ، ولكن من
غير
المحتمل
في أذهان المسار الذي
كان عليه  تم طرده من روسيا لكننا
سنرى أننا سنرى أنه من غير المحتمل
اقتراح استحضار المادة 4 أو الخامسة
من سيدي حلف شمال الأطلسي
، والسؤال هو أنه من المحتمل أن نعقد
اجتماعًا لسفراء أه
حتى يبدو أننا '  سأذهب إلى
المرحلة التالية ، شكرًا لك ، حسنًا ، شكرًا يا رفاق ، الذين
دعوتهم أولاً للتحدث في بالي إندونيسيا
، أريد أن أذهب إلى فيل ماتينجلي الذي كان
يقف إلى جانب فيل هام ،
قال الرئيس إنه من غير المحتمل أن يكون قد تم
طرده من روسيا مما قد يعني
إطلاقه من قبل الروس في الداخل  أوكرانيا أو
نوعًا من أنظمة الدفاع الجوي الأوكرانية أو
أي شيء آخر
، كان من المدهش أنه قال أنه على
الرغم من
نعم ، فأنا في الواقع مندهش تمامًا
من الرئيس ، لقد كان ذلك صريحًا بشأن
ما سيحدثون به.  آخ الآن فيما
يتعلق بالعملية وأعتقد أن هذا
يمنحك أيضًا نافذة جيدة جدًا
لمعرفة سبب توخي الحذر الشديد بشأن
الإدلاء بأي تصريحات حول ما
حدث بالضبط على
مدار المساء وتذكر
الرئيس ورئيسه  الفريق يعمل
على هذا أه منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
عندما كانوا في البداية
وتحدث الرئيس مباشرة مع الرئيس البولندي
وكان فريقه على اتصال مباشر
مع نظرائهم البولنديين
على مدار الساعات العديدة
الماضية أيضًا ثم بعد ذلك  كان هناك هذا
الاجتماع الطارئ الذي دعا إليه
الرئيس بايدن وحضره
قادة مجموعة الدول السبع الأعضاء في حلف شمال الأطلسي الموجودين
هنا في بالي من أجل مجموعة العشرين أيضًا ، لكن
الرئيس قال صراحةً إنه
لم يؤمن أو على الأقل لم
يفهم ذلك.  تم إطلاقه من روسيا
مرة أخرى ، وهناك عناصر أخرى هنا
حيث
ربما يكون من الواضح أن حلفاء روسيا من قوات الحلفاء الروس لديهم
حلفاء في المنطقة قد
يكونون مسؤولين عن  أو أن هذه كانت
مهمة صريحة تمامًا نظرًا
لحقيقة أن المسؤولين الأمريكيين كانوا حذرين للغاية
حتى هذه النقطة ، أعتقد أنها تساعد حقًا في
التأكيد على سبب
عدم استعداد المسؤولين الأمريكيين للذهاب إلى أبعد من
الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
مثل الآخرين  لقد عبروا عن قلقهم
بشأن الأصول هنا وأعتقد أن أعطي
بعض السياق لأندرسون حول سبب
أهمية
هذا الأمر ، فهذه
لعبة كرة مختلفة تمامًا لا تقلل
من كل عشرات الصواريخ التي
تتساقط على أوكرانيا خلال
بالأمس والليلة الماضية ، ولكن إذا تعرض أحد
حلفاء الناتو للهجوم من قبل روسيا ، مما أدى إلى تفعيل
المادة 5 التي تطلق الدفاع الجماعي ،
فهذا شيء
قاله الرئيس مرارًا وتكرارًا بما في ذلك على
الأرض في وارسو أنه لا
يمكن لروسيا أن تتطرق إلى شبر واحد من أراضي الناتو
بدون  أ القوة
الكاملة لاستجابة حلفاء الناتو وهذا هو سبب
توخيهم الحذر الشديد وهذا هو السبب في
أنهم كانوا منهجيين للغاية
والرئيس